تركزت الاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريعه امس الجمعه في
العاصمه الخرطوم وشهدت المنطقه الجنوبيه
من العاصمه عمليات عسكريه ام ثلاث سيما
احياء الصحافات وجبرى والمدينه الرياضيه
التي تحتوي على معسكر للدعم السريع الجيش
السوداني يقول انه ينفذ عمليات تمشيط من
اجل ما وصفه بطرد الدعم السريع من المناطق
الواقعه بين نهري النيل الازرق والابيض
والتي تمتد نحو عشره كيلومترات كما تتركز
العمليات في شارع الستين الذي يربط
المنطقه الجنوبيه للخرطوم بوسط العاصمه
وفي منطقه
المسعوديه بين ولايتي الخرطوم والجزيره
اندلعت مواجهات بين الدعم السريع والجيش
خصوصا في مصانع شركه جياد حيث افاد مصدرهم
في الشركه للجزيره للجيشه يطارد الدعم
السريع بعد محاوله فاشله لاقتحام المصانع
وتتقطع الاشتباكاته في وسط الخرطوم
وتحديدا في محيط المطار والقصر الجمهوري
ومحيط القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه